queen elizabeth dead at 96.
in the hours before the monarch's final
moments the royal family rushed to
scotland to be by her side
we are looking here at images of
balmoral castle this is the entrance to
the estate this is where the queen
has been in residence
since the month of july
e.t can confirm that prince harry
traveled to balmoral castle without his
wife meghan markle other members of the
royal family also made the trip
including harry's father prince charles
charles's wife camilla and harry's older
brother prince william
that's the duke of cambridge driving
prince andrew prince edward and his wife
sophie into balmoral
as for william's wife kate she stayed
home to be with their three kids prince
george princess charlotte and prince
louis
thursday marks their first day of school
prior to announcing the queen's death
buckingham palace released a statement
thursday giving an update on the queen's
health
quote following further evaluation this
morning the queen's doctors are
concerned for her majesty's health and
have recommended she remain under
medical supervision
the queen remains comfortable and at
balmoral
buckingham palace has not been in the
habit of giving updates but i think on
this occasion there will have to be
something given the level of concern
that there is not just here but around
the world um and we've seen the other
members of the royal family arriving at
balmoral that in itself is an indication
i think of just how serious the
situation is
queen elizabeth who turned 96 in april
has had her health closely monitored
since october as she battled some
mobility issues that forced her to
cancel several appearances both public
and private
other family members attended in her
place
we've been very lucky all these years
that the queen has been so visible that
she has been so many audiences in person
and she has had an incredible energy
that she has brought to her public life
but there without a doubt we are seeing
less of her we have seen her carry out
less public engagement more virtual
engagement
as for what's next we know there's a
royal protocol in place
when the queen does pass there is a plan
in place um it is part of what we call
the bridge plans and the plan for the
queen is known as london bridge and the
first person to be informed the queen's
death will be the prime minister
and after that it will be the royal
household who will make the news
official and to the public so when the
event actually happens it will be made
public you will know that it is
absolutely real not fake news and the
royal website will be blacked out with a
short statement confirming the queen's
death
you